welcome back to las vegas now whatever
life challenges you're facing better
help the sponsors of this next segment
are here to help see how easy it is to
get started check it out
the best way to think about therapy is
through analogies we get our cars fixed
to prevent bigger issues down the road
right we work out and visit the doctor
to prevent injury and disease in our
bodies we see the dentist for our teeth
to prevent cavities and other issues so
therapy is like all of the above it's
routine maintenance for your mental and
emotional wellness to prevent bigger
issues down the road going to therapy
doesn't mean something's wrong with you
it means you're investing in yourself to
keep your mind healthy better help is
the largest professional therapy
platform they offer customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't even have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to and
everything you tell your therapist is
completely confidential better help
employees more than 25 000 therapists in
all of them have a masters or doctorate
degree in their field they specialize in
specific issues such as stress anxiety
relationships parenting depression
addictions eating sleeping trauma anger
family conflicts lgbt matters
grief religion self-esteem and the list
goes on and it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours there's even a weekly membership
subscription that includes one weekly
live session and unlimited messaging and
you can even cancel at any time for any
reason why invest in everything else and
not in your mind reach out to betterhelp
today by going to betterhelp.com
thanks to betterhelp for sponsoring this
segment today's viewers get 20 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
2022 that's betterhelp.com
that's a great offer